bonsoir le dérèglement climatique
parlons-en il suffit de voir ce début de
mois de juillet pour s'en rendre compte
la france en tout cas comme tous les
pays va devoir agir est d'ailleurs le
projet de loi climat et résilience doit
être un pas en ce sens aux yeux du
gouvernement le président de la
république a même promis un référendum
sur le climat pour faire entrer dans la
constitution l'obligation de garantir la
préservation de l'environnement mais ça
ne fait pas l'unanimité et en
particulier les sénateurs qui font une
bataille de blocage contre cette
définition pour les français en tout cas
l'écologie est devenue c'est certain une
préoccupation
sinon quotidienne au moins importante
est ce que ce sera un enjeu pour
l'élection présidentielle de l'année
prochaine ça c'est une tout autre
question
en attendant ce soir dans l'émission
publique le rendait au public chaque
lundi sur lcp public sénat avec le
figaro
nous recevons barbara pour philippe
françois ancien vous êtes ministre de la
transition écologique
on va commencer par parler de la
vaccination parce que ça c'est vraiment
au coeur des débats aussi faut-il la
rendre obligatoire ou pas il semblerait
qu'il ya un consensus au gouvernement
pour dire qu'il faut rendre obligatoire
au moins pour les soignants c'est ça la
question est clairement sur la table
aujourd'hui 50 % d'aidé soignant
notamment en ehpad
ils ne sont pas vaccinés aujourd'hui il
faut que l'on se pose collectivement la
question de comment on peut aider les
plus fragiles et comment on peut aider
ceux qui sont les plus exposés on sait
que dans les ehpad
il y à des risques même si les personnes
sont vaccinées et donc les personnels
soignants qui sont à leurs contacts qui
sont dans leur mission vis-à-vis d'eux
moi je les appelle et les encourage à
continuer leur mission à la poursuivre
en faisant cette vaccination c'est le
message du gouvernement on va parler un
petit peu d anti vaccin parce que quand
on regarde qui sont les anti vaccins y
en a un petit peu partout mais on les
retrouve notamment dans la sphère
écologistes au sens large du terme je
parle pas du parti europe ecologie les
verts seulement mais dans la sphère
écologistes comment vous expliquez ça
coûtait
moi je l'expliquent certainement par
manque d'information et un manque de
recul moi je vais vous dire les choses
très simplement je suis écologiste je
suis vacciné ma fille est vacciné et
j'encourage tout le monde à se vacciner
c'est à dire que l'écologie n'est pas
antinomique du vaccin
évidemment mais pourtant ça fait de la
dea entre autres les les gens qui
veulent pas vaccinés qui disent bas
parce que c'est des produits chimiques
qu'on nous met dans le corps parce qu'on
ne sait pas quelles sont les retombées
pour la santé c'est culturel ou si
encore une fois regardons l'histoire
les vaccins ont sauvé des millions de
vies des millions de vies un vaccin
bien sûr comme tout médicament ça peut
avoir des effets indésirables mais les
effets indésirables sont d'abord
vérifier sont étudiées et nous avons des
agences de santé qui sont là pour
valider les vaccins une fois que les
vaccins sont validées vaccinons nous
nous en avons besoin pour retrouver tous
une vie normale pour éviter une
troisième vague une quatrième vague
maintenant même qui malheureusement
pourrait se profiler comme l'a dit mon
collègue olivier ferrand donc soyons
tous responsables vaccinons nous pour
retrouver le plus vite possible une vie
normale j'étais tout à l'heure vous êtes
au centre de l'actualité notamment avec
votre projet de loi constitutionnelle
sur le climat dont on va parler avec bgi
de bouche et de lcp assemblée nationale
pour son origine - francis et steve
jourdain de public sénat brigitte
concernant marabout qui lisent sénat
rejette votre projet de loi
constitutionnelle sur le climat vous
vous y attendiez côté jeu comme je vois
ce qui s'est passé sur la loi climat et
résilience qui est un autre pan de la
politique que nous menons en matière de
transition écologique
je constate que j'avais quelques doutes
et bien là les doutes se lève je
constate que manifestement les sénateurs
sont contre la transition écologique
ils ont un vidé de sa substance une
bonne partie du projet de loi climat
résilience et là ils empêchent puisque
c'est ça qui se passe il empêche de
faire ce référendum que nous attendons
pour recréer un grand débat sur cette
question qui nous dépasse je suis je
crois partagée entre
la colère est en même temps l'envié de
continuer la colère face à des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à dépasser les postures
les postures idéologiques pour aller
dans le sens du bien commun
l'écologie c'est notre combat à tous on
a l'occasion de le mettre dans la
constitution et la détermination parce
que je me dis que je serai toujours aux
côtés de ceux qui veulent y arriver
maintenant malheureusement le temps
presse le gouvernement avait quand même
fait pression juste avant christophe
castaner avait lancé un appel solennel à
à gérard larcher
ça n'a visiblement pas suffi gabriela
talent parle de climato-sceptiques
sceptique c'est comme ça que vous
définiriez finalement les sénateurs eux
les républicains ils s'en défendent
quand j'étais au sénat ces dernières
semaines sur le projet de loi climat
résilience tout le monde me disait bien
sûr le climat c'est un enjeu important
la protection de l'environnement c'est
très important sauf que quand il s'agit
de s'y mettre
quand il s'agit de prendre des décisions
et bien là on voit que c'est beaucoup
plus digeste que ce sont des climato
sceptiques
en tout cas ce serait tout ce qui est
tout ce que ça veut dire derrière ce
sont des climato inactifs ce sont des
climato résigné je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ce ne sont pas vous me voyez
pas jusqu'à dire qu'il est aux
sceptiques parce que ça veut dire
beaucoup de choses
il refuse de refuse de dire qu'ils le
sont il se comporte comme s'il était
clairement et moi l'appel que je fais
c'est il y avait un appel à gérard
larcher et bien jeunes prolongent gérard
larcher monsieur le président trouvons
des solutions pour aboutir ce serait
honteux pour la classe politique et en
taux pour les sénateurs si on n'arrivait
pas à arriver à un référendum
à la fin de la course que maintenant que
les sénateurs ont voté contre le fait
que la solution à bas on peut toujours
trouver un terrain d'entente
sauf que la zone union en gros c'est non
non non non aux réunions comme si ça
n'est pas aussi est-ce que c'est
inscrire ce texte à l'ordre du jour côté
de moi je ne sais même plus si on a le
temps maintenant parce qu'à force de
tergiverser à force de perdre du temps
là les sénateurs reprennent une version
qui est une version où ils ne font pas
de pas les parlementaires les députés
avaient fait un pas les sénateurs
reviennent sur une sur une écriture dont
il ça franchement barbares puisqu'il y
arriver vous dites que vous êtes étonnés
vraiment étonné que les sénateurs
rejette cet axe est pas un joli petit
cette histoire tenez vous avez dit que
vous étiez en colère
oui je suis en colère parce que je ce
que je redoutais se passe je pensais que
les uns et des autres étaient capables
de se dépasser pour un intérêt supérieur
qui est l'intérêt de notre avenir commun
qui est l'intérêt de nos enfants
eh bien je vois accueillant c'est un bon
enneigement bull depuis le départ cette
histoire de référendum
si emmanuel macron avait souhaité ce
référendum il aurait pu faire autrement
pas l'article le 11 par exemple non
locaux institutions non non non non la
lazio 2 vous l'avez fait en 60 de ce que
de gaulle à 169 oui mais là on est sur
une procédure qui nécessite de voter
deux textes identiques à la sangle
aurait pu demander aux français de
s'exprimer sur ce qu'est sur cette
question non sur la réforme de la
constitution c'est une réforme pardon
qui passe par spécifique est donc là le
projet de réforme doit être votée dans
les mêmes termes par l'assemblée et le
sénat puis après passer soit par le
congrès soit par le référendum le
président avait choisi la voie du
résultat la voilà cette voie là il n'y
aura donc pas de référendum sur ce point
ah mais moi je suis acte et je ne suis
je vous savez je suis écologiste si je
baisser les bras
au moindre problème et au moindre
obstacle je peux vous dire ça fait
longtemps que j'aurais fait autre chose
que de la politique il peut encore y
avoir un référendum
j'essaye d'y croire toujours et surtout
je serai toujours aux côtés de ce qui va
lui arriver
et encore une fois ce qui n'est ce
qu'ils font en sorte qu'on n'y arrive
pas or ont cette responsabilité sur
l'idée de lecture politique vous en
faites ce que c'est un désaveu pour
emmanuel macron qui s'était engagé après
la convention citoyenne
le président emmanuel macron s'est
engagé à porter ce texte et a porté
cette réforme devant les assemblées
après le rôle des parlementaires c'est
aussi d'être à la hauteur et en
l'occurrence là les sénateurs ne le sont
pas mais on sait qu'il aura pas de
commission mixte paritaire comme on dit
il n'y aura pas de point en fin de
réunion d'accord en fait entre
l'assemblée et le sénat puisque c'est un
projet de loi constitutionnelle
ça veut dire qu'il faut si vous voulez
aller au référendum l'inscrire à nouveau
à l'ordre du jour tout à l'heure vous
avez dit je ne sais pas s'il y a le
temps donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on acte
la fin du référendum
ça va faire l'objet de discussions on a
un agenda parlementaire qui est chargé
très chargé et nous avons beaucoup de
réformes que nous voulons continuer de
faire passer puisqu'il on veut continuer
les réformes le plus tard possible donc
dans cet agenda chargé est ce qu'on va
réussir à réinscrire le texte qui est ce
qu'il faut c'est maintenant voir s'il ya
possibilité d'atterrir sur un livret
vous aller plaider pour sarah sa
réinscription bien sûr est ce que ce
sera une priorité aux yeux du
gouvernement vu que l'agenda est chargé
justement il ya une question de
priorités il ya une question de
possibilités est-ce que ce revers mérité
le président de la république a dit très
clairement qu'ils souhaitaient un
référendum nous avons demandé à
plusieurs reprises à ce que les
sénateurs fasse l'effort de trouver une
rédaction qui soit une rédaction sur
laquelle on puisse atterrir cette
démarche pour l'instant ne trouve pas de
lui puisque les puisque les scénarii
vous n'avez ce la mort du référendum ce
soir un million jeunes acte jamais rien
vous savez on doit continuer à se battre
moi j'appelle gérard larcher parlé avec
la majorité sénatoriale pour voir si on
peut arriver à un terrain d'entente ya
alors il ya aussi le projet de loi
climat et résilience c'est complètement
autre chose parce que c'est changer
notre quotidien avec des points très
précis si oui c'est un peu votre texte
un baba pompili c'est un texte très
dense il ya 200 articles
au total les sénateurs ont voté un
amendement qui prévoit la baisse de la
tva sur les billets de train est ce que
vous allez reprendre cette mesure c'est
une mesure écolo vous l'avez dit c'est
un engagement très globale ce texte on
veut faire entrer l'écologie dans le
quotidien des français donc dans tous
les aspects de leur vie que temps pour
lancer exemple de dieu sur cet exemple
là on a décidé de faire en sorte qu'on
préfère le train à l'avion avec une
mesure très forte qui est que
on interdit les lignes d'avion quand il
ya une alternative sur la boîte ailleurs
sur les billets de trois classes
la deuxième chose importante c'est de
faire baisser les prix des billets c'est
ça qui est important
et donc il ya plusieurs méthodes pour
faire baisser les prix des billets la
méthode qu'a choisi le gouvernement
c'est plutôt que de s'en référer à une
tva à 5,5 dont on n'est pas sûr du tout
qu'elle sera reporté sur les prix des
billets qu'il y aura une influence sur
les prix du billet
chacun peut se souvenir de ce qui
s'était passé sur la restauration donc
plutôt que de faire la tva à 5,5 dont on
n'était pas sûr de son effet on a fait
un travail avec la sncf notamment en
l'aidant dans le plan de relance pour
qu'elle se reconstruise suite à la crise
et qu'elles puissent proposer ce qu'elle
avait sur lui bien ce nom comme vous
l'avez vu mon nom ce qui est intéressant
là c'est la baisse de la tva ou c'est la
baisse des prix des billets est nommé
judith moi je ne suis pas pour des
totems et la méthode qui a été choisi
par le gouvernement c'est une baisse des
prix des billets maintenant et si vous
allez sur le site internet de la sncf
pour voir les prix des billets vous
verrez que les prix y ont effectivement
baissé autres mesures intéressantes les
menus végétariens dans les cantines
scolaires les sénateurs ils ont rejeté
en la généralisation de cette mesure est
ce que vous allez la rétablira ce que
c'est important pour vous oui et alors
là pour être très clair je me désole
qu'on soit encore en 2021 obligé de se
battre sur ces histoires de menus
végétariens le menu végétarien c'est
quelque chose qui permet de donner un
choix à tous si en plus c'est ça c'est
une ceinture alors c'est là ce qui était
dans le texte de loi c'était la
généralisation de ce qui était dans
égalise
c'est à dire un menu par semaine dans
toutes les cantines de france qui soit
végétarien et puis après il y avait des
débats sur un monsieur quand il ya
plusieurs menus ajouté un menu
végétarien qu'on puisse donner ce choix
qu'on puisse permettre aussi de manger
moins de viande mais de la viande de
meilleure qualité et de la viande qu'ils
soient de la viande de nos terroirs
comme on dit on a la chance d'avoir en
france des très bonnes que vous allez
rétablir cette mesure donc bien sûr que
nous allons rétablir cette mesure qui
est une mesure simple on doit réfléchir
à ce qu'on mange la viande
l'élevage c'est 15% des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde est sur
le terrain on craignait ce que les mères
traîne un peu des pieds mais en
l'occurrence c'est le contraire là où
l'expérimentation a été fait pour
égaliser
c'est quasiment partout eh bien ça se
passe globalement très bien il ya même
eu des recherches des faits sur le
gaspillage puisque on avait un peu peur
qui est du gaspillage
au contraire on voit que ça ne crée pas
saine génère pas plus de gaspillage
qu'ailleurs et ça génère aussi une
réflexion entre tout le monde sur
justement comment on élabore les
nouveaux menus
comment on essaye les papilles des
enfants sur des nouveaux goûts et c'est
donc en général c'est plutôt très
instructif pour tout le monde
zut alors à propos des mers toujours il
ya la droite qui veut leur donner à un
droit de veto contre l'installation de
nouvelles éoliennes
pourquoi ne pas leur accorder ce droit
que beaucoup de maires réclament
d'ailleurs tout à fait et là vous
montrer encore des reculs qui ont été
faits par le sénat les menus végétariens
ce droit pour les mères les sénateurs se
disent les représentants des
collectivités or là ils empêchent les
maires d'avoir cette possibilité de
réglementer ce qui se passe dans les
vitrines des magasins alors qu'ils
peuvent réglementer ce qui se passe
devant et qui est aussi visible donc
tout ça est assurée les merlus auront
pas le droit de veto contre
l'installation des érudits alors sur les
éoliennes sur les éoliennes il leur
donne alors là pour le coup un cadeau
empoisonné
puisque on sait que sur les éoliennes il
peut y avoir des pressions très dur très
forte d'un certain nombre d'années si le
roman non c'est d'abord tous ne le
réclame pas et pour ceux qui n'auraient
pas une question alors d'assumer da à
eux d'assumer à un moment la politique
de transition énergétique
c'est une politique nationale c'est une
politique avec des objectifs nationaux
et dans la loi climat résilience on va
les décliner au niveau des régions
on va mettre en place des concertations
parce que c'est ça qui a manqué on a
certains ont eu le sentiment d'avoir des
éoliennes qui poussaient comme ça un
petit peu partout on a besoin de
développer les renouvelables
quoi qu'on fasse après d'ailleurs sur
les jonctions concertation plutôt que le
droit de veto et donc il faut de la
concertation on va mettre en place aussi
et j'ai demandé au préfet de faire une
cartographie des endroits où on peut
mettre des éoliennes avec plein de en
regardant la biodiversité en gardant le
patrimoine culturel en regardant s'il ya
du vent tout bêtement ça peut être les
différents obstacles et donc en
regardant on ne peut les mettre et donc
une fois qu'on aura les objectifs par
région en disant voilà on a besoin de
temps d'éoliennes dans cette région en
ayant une cartographie on pourra mettre
tout le monde autour de la table y
compris les porteurs de projet et dire
voilà on doit en même temps où peut-on
les mettre où il ya de l'encerclement il
faut pas qu'on ait fait la queue les
moeurs pourront faire agir avec la droit
de veto enfin autour des taux
forfaitaires mêlée l'intérêt moi ce que
je veux c'est sortir de la guerre là
dessus et ceux de faire les choses
intelligemment que tout le monde puisse
se mettre d'accord
on a besoin de ces énergies regardons
ensemble ou on aimait donnons-nous de la
perspective comme ça on sait où il y en
aura où il y en aura pas et puisque je
veux aussi c'est que les citoyens
puissent s'investir sur les projets
d'éoliennes puisque là où ça se fait
dans d'autres pays mais aussi en france
ça marche très bien
c'est l'heure est au doute et au coeur
vous avez veulent en tirer des bénéfices
a vu ce que ça a été récupéré ou en tout
cas au moins des élections régionales
notamment par le rassemblement national
des éoliennes
tout à fait mais le devenir un problème
politique le rassemblement national
n'est pas là pour apporter des solutions
il est là pour grossir avec les
problèmes alors le but de tout ça c'est
de réduire les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre l'europe vient de fixer ou une
baisse de 55 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici à 2030 or dans
votre projet love ou rester à 40%
est ce que vous êtes suffisamment
ambitieux et pourquoi vous n'allez pas
assez 55% est ce que vous avez tout
simplement peur de ne pas arriver déjà
aux 40%
on essaye de faire les choses avec
méthode
on a un projet de loi qui était fondée
sur cet objectif qui est toujours fondée
sur cet objectif de 40%
mon objectif est d'ailleurs je le fais
parce que celui imposé mais aussi parce
que nous sommes regardés c'est très
normal
mon objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
tout ce qu'on met dans ce projet de loi
soit appliquée ensuite avec tous les
textes d'application et je serai très
vigilante là dessus l'europe a relevé
ses arts
v ses propres objectifs on est en
négociations pour voir comment ces
objectifs se dispatchent au sein des
différents états membres puisque ça peut
pas se sera pas forcément le même
objectif selon il est à moi donc en
fonction des négociations que nous
allons avoir
nous allons pouvoir apporter notre
pierre et là ce sera une moyenne 55% par
exemple offert 60 et d'autres 30 tout à
fait c'est une moyenne en fonction des
points de départ de ou chaque pays et il
faudra changer la loi
du coup non il faudra pas changer la loi
par contre on est quatre gars et on fait
ça correctement c'est pour ça qu'on va
pas faire ça au détour d'un amendement
on est en train de regarder dans quel
domaine on peut essayer de pousser plus
loin avec quels moyens comment et ça ça
demande un tout petit peu mais les 40%
vous êtes déjà sûr d'y arriver
les 40 % on fait tout pour y arriver et
on a des études qui montrent que si on
met en place tout ce qu'on a dit avec
volontarisme et bien et surtout en
revenant sur les reculs évidemment opéré
par les sénateurs eh bien on devrait
pouvoir rien
autre sujet par pompe il est vous êtes
personnellement poursuivi en justice par
des militants écologistes pour une
action climatique
c'est un délit qui peut aller jusqu'à
deux ans de prison et trois cent mille
euros damende comme les taux reviennent
trois fois trente mille euros damende
quand vous avez réagi quand vous savez a
pris un set quand il a pris connaissance
de cette plainte
j'ai vu c'était une opération de com à
ces loupés d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé sa fin
voilà je moi j'ai pas trop a commenté ce
genre de choses ce que je vois c'est que
ces personnes qui font ce genre d'action
sont très promptes à attaquer à
critiquer ce qui ne va pas et à la
limite c'est tout à fait leur droit et
c'est tout moi j'ai toujours pensé que
c'était important qu'on ait des ong qui
nous titille et qui nous pousse qui nous
motive à avancer plus maintenant
j'aimerais bien aussi que ces mêmes
personnes soit un peu plus présente
quand je dois me battre pour développer
des énergies renouvelables quand je dois
me battre
quand il s'agit de mettre en place des
zones à faibles émissions pour lutter
contre la pollution de l'air qui tue 40
mille personnes par an mais elle a quand
je dois me battre face à des gens qui
sont très opposées à cela ou même parce
qu'il y en a qui ne comprennent pas bien
pourquoi on fait ça et là il n'y a plus
personne dans le jeu suivant jour un
petit peu mon fils y est alors allé sur
le terrain pour pour essayer de trouver
des soies justice le conseil d'état
vient d'un team et au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures pour le climat d'ici
neuf mois concrètement qu'est ce que
vous allez mettre en oeuvre ben ça
revient un peu ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure dans les suites de la loi
climat résidence puisque le conseil
d'état comme vous le vous l'avez dit
vous-même
en fait le conseil d'état dit pour
atteindre ces objectifs de 40 de baisse
de 40% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030
il faut mettre en place un certain
nombre de mesures dans les neuf mois
dans les neuf mois et on se meuble en
baisse dans les neuf mois c'est
l'objectif de la fin du quinquennat ce
son est ce que c'est noble jeu ah ben
moi je vais tout faire pour que ce soit
nam mon rôle c'est de le faire et donc
on a la loi climat résilience qui est en
fait le véhicule pour cela il y à
d'autres véhicules mais principalement
c'est ce véhicule là et donc moi ce que
je vais faire c'est mettre en place le
plus vite possible tous les outils
d'application de cette loi notamment les
décrets d'application ont des décrets
d'application vous savez pour son rang
pour les ordures un peu longue mais on
va faire en sorte que sa rentrée le
conseil d'état il est dans son rôle
quand il vous intime st mais le conseil
d'état en fait il a été saisi pour dans
le cadre d'une affaire et le conseil
d'état actions ou inactions nous pose
nous posent des questions en nous
comment allez-vous faire dorer dans son
ordre vos objets qu'on n'y voyait pas
une attaque personnelle bien sûr vous
savez ce que je constate c'est que il ya
de plus en plus de juridiction on l'a vu
en allemagne en avis aux pays bas qui se
penche sur ces questions là je crois que
c'est positif parce que quelque part ça
montre qu enfin le droit et le droit de
chaque pays le droit européen droit
international prennent en compte la
protection des tonnes au gouvernement
parce que les décisions du conseil
d'état qui ont été prises qui ont fait
beaucoup réagir y compris le président
d'un tube en disant que c'était pas du
niveau du conseil d'état ça détonne un
petit peu depuis le 1er juillet les prix
du gaz ont augmenté de 10 % 10 % c'est
énorme c'est une augmentation qui est
lié tout simplement au cours de du du
gaz sera resté jambes c'est une
augmentation qui est liée au cours du
gaz qui est dit aussi au fait qu'on a eu
un mois d'avril très froid et qu'on
n'avait pas assez de renouvelables qui
fonctionnait donc cesser hausse du prix
on est obligé de les faire entrer en
application
maintenant on a mis en place beaucoup d
aide pour justement aider les personnes
qui ont le plus de mal à payer leurs
factures notamment avec l'augmentation
du chèque énergie le chèque énergie en
as 350 mille personnes de plus ménages
de plus que peuvent ces distributeurs de
gaz finalement de renoncer à ces hausses
non cela venu en tout cas au moins on ne
peut pas renoncer aux hausses parce que
on est obligé de suivre les prix ont peu
disais qu'on allait la bouche avec des
prix du marché
oui mais décalée en fait c'est décalé le
problème nous ce qu'on préfère c'est
aider les personnes qui ont des
difficultés on les aide de deux manières
il y a le chèque énergie qui est un
chèque qui qui est distribué de plus en
plus on est à 150 euros en moyenne de
chèques énergie et puis on aide aussi
les personnes à avoir moins besoin de de
payer leur chauffage c'est à dire en
baissant leurs factures grâce aux
travaux une heure les quais dans les
aides avec ma prime rénove avec
l'accompagnateur enough qui est dans la
loi climat résilience bref faire en
sorte que leurs factures baisse
durablement d'une effectivement les
syndicats et les parlementaires de
gauche sont opposés au projet et recule
c'est un projet qui prévoit de scinder
en trois entités edf on sait que le
président emmanuel
ac on va bientôt rendre un arbitrage
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'il
pourrait y renoncer
c'est un projet déjà kiné qui n'est plus
du tout d'une faible + recul non mais
parce qu'il a changé
en fait il a beaucoup évolué parce qu'il
ya des négociations depuis un certain
temps maintenant avec la commission
parce que nous voulons nous que le
groupe reste un groupe intégré où on
garde le statut des agents ou en garde
son côté public mais qui nous permettent
aussi de gérer un certain nombre de
problèmes par exemple les problèmes que
nous avons sur les renouvellements de
concessions hydroélectriques donc pas
question de relancer ce projet c'est une
négociation globale on ne veut pas y
aller contre contre les contre
évidemment les mariés des salariés qui
travaillent là bas et on veut qu'il y
ait un vrai débat
mais pour l'instant le sujet c'est les
négociations avec la commission
nous ne ferons pas un projet au rabais
donc pour l'instant les négociations
quand ils n'ont pas un sens n'y a pas de
projets viables à quoi il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas encore d'accord avec la
commission et on sait quand emmanuel
mâcon va rendre son arbitrage
pour l'instant je vous dis on continue
de laisser les négociations se continuer
je vous rappelle quand même que de toute
façon on va avoir un sujet puisque l'un
des principaux sujets c'est la reine qui
est qui et internet de soutien en fait à
l'électricité et à la fabrication
d'électricité
ce tarif va s'arrêter en 2025 d'ici là
il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
merci brigitte et steve s'il est à lundi
prochain
vous étiez aujourd'hui au havre aux
côtés d'edouard philippe alors on a pas
d'image de d'aujourd'hui vous parlez
photovoltaïque avec la cie a promis ce
que vous avez connu à matignon alors on
voit qu'ils edouard philippe edouard
philippe
est ce que c'était un bon premier
ministre vous n'étiez pas sa ministre
mais ce que c'était un bon premier
ministre
oui c'est un bon premier ministre qui a
eu affaire à des crises du rhin il a
géré la crise et gilet jaune il a géré
la première partie de la crise de l'aco
vide et ils agiraient je crois de la
manière la plus pragmatique possible et
à moi comme à d'autres ce qui m'a
impressionné c'est sa capacité aussi à
dire les choses simplement clairement a
avoué aussi quand ils ne savaient pas je
crois que c'est c'est une fois pour être
un bon candidat à la présidentielle à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas du tout
candidat à la présidentielle
vous allez dans le documentaire qui est
passé hier sur france 5 il se pose des
questions il laisse toutes les pistes
ouvertes
écoutez moi je suis membre du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron je suis
dans l'équipe présidentielle je
travaille pour le bilan des manuels
macron donc je vais pas m'amuser à faire
des ddd vous se jeter et théorie parce
que ce serait il ya tellement de
candidats présidentiels et qu'aux sages
vont vous dire c'est qu'edouard philippe
quand j'étais avec lui au havre
aujourd'hui m'a beaucoup parlé de sa
ville m'a beaucoup parlé de ce qu'il
faisait dans sa ville et pour la
transition écologique on apporte de
france de la fabrication d'éoliennes
offshore au havre qui va être un des
bateaux amiraux de la construction
d'éoliennes en mer en france
voilà de quoi nous avons parlé et
maintenant on accueille yves thréard
bonsoir yves ossonce et directeur
adjoint du figaro
bonsoir barbara pompiers alors il ya une
nouvelle qui est tombée cet après midi
c'est le garde des sceaux qui est
convoqué par la cour de justice de la
république le 16 juillet pour une
histoire de conflit d'intérêts assez
compliqué d'ailleurs il va pouvoir
rester
garde des sceaux alors que on sait qu'il
ya une mise en examen
de façon presque garanti ce jour-là
demandé à moi d'avoir un avis là dessus
oui j'ai pas d'avis là dessus parce
qu'elles sont pas à moi de prendre des
décisions de sinistrés quand on est mis
en examen
écoutez encore une fois ce n'est pas à
moi de prendre ce genre de décision dans
la mesure du possible ce qu'il faut
c'est toujours laisser la justice faire
son travail correctement je vais pas
vous je vais pas vous ressortir les
éléments de langage habituels mais c'est
la séparation des pouvoirs ça s'appelle
j'y suis très attaché d'accord alors
eric dupond moretti c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui est de votre région la
grande région des hautes falaises
il est parti au combat pour les
élections les élections régionales là
bas avec d'autres ministres d'ailleurs
et il a fait un score plutôt assez
médiocre enfin bon il n'a pas été retenu
est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'était sa place
d'aller dans ce genre de de scrutin
alors que c'est pas un professionnel à
la politique non plus mais enfin il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut quand même on a
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui disent
il faut du renouvellement on en a marre
de la vieille classe politique etc
et puis après quand on a des personnes
qui arrivent avec leur énergie avec
leurs envies
eric dupond-moretti des quand même connu
pour cette beaucoup investi dans son
domaine inquiet le domaine de la justice
qui a des compétences pour le sujet
quand ils arrivent en gabarre oui mais
ce n'est pas un professionnel de la
politique ferait savoir donc tranché en
tout cas il est il et il est ministre il
fait son travail de ministre
et puis il a voulu porter le message qui
est un message qu'il porte depuis
toujours qui est un message de lutte
contre le rassemblement national
il la portait après les électeurs
voulaient partager tous ce message sur
le front national comme en général
ben je vais pas je ne veux pas répéter
que lui quand même sur beaucoup de
choses dites moi sur quoi voit notamment
sur le féminisme
ah ben il me semble qu'ils portent le
message de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes de l'égalité des droits et de
la qualité dans tous les sens de ce que
vous attendez pas ce que peu partie des
françaises n'attendent que le premier le
col le président de la république
s'exprime après ces élections pour nous
dire qu'est ce qu'il va faire jusqu'à à
l'élection présidentielle oui je crois
que ce serait une bonne chose que
c'était oui qui donne qui donne un peu
le cap de la fin de ce quinquennat
on a beaucoup de dossiers on en a parlé
de quelques-uns mais on a un agenda de
réformes qui est un agenda lourd d'ici
la fin de l'année et qu'il donne les
grandes directions je pense que ce
serait une bonne puisqu'elle veut dire
que vous ne voyez pas le cap là pour le
moment on a un cap mais c'est toujours
bien de réaffirmer un cap régulièrement
alors il vous a il a prêté content après
vous ce que vous avez critiqué la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
votre mouvement aux commandes en tous
les cas vole un mouvement commun c'est
toujours le cas et vous a fait une
réflexion non il ya le
le fait que la majorité présidentielle
soit une majorité qui composait de
sensibilités différentes c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît extrêmement sain qui
est bon pour le débat et qui permet
justement d'avancé j'ai toujours cru que
j'étais je suis convaincu que le débat
démocratique est une manière de faire
avancer les choses
donc nous sommes en soutien du président
en soutien de cette majorité avec une
richesse supplémentaire avec des débats
que nous mettons sur la table et cette
position sur l'assurance chômage était
une position qui était connue depuis
longtemps et par exemple s'ils
reprenaient la la on attend d'ailleurs
on est le on retient notre souffle mais
est-ce qu'on va reprendre la réforme des
retraites
vous êtes pour le sujet sur la table
apparemment le projet qui serait en
réflexion est un projet qui ne serait
pas le même que celui qui avait été
présenté il ya maintenant deux ans plus
tard edouard philippe
là il y à des consultations des groupes
parlementaires je pense qu'il faut faire
les choses en ordre là il ya des
consultations ces consultations vont
permettre d'alimenter la réflexion
et puis après on verra si cette réforme
est fait on pas et c'est peut-être aussi
l'occasion au président de la république
d'en parler s'ils souhaitent s'exprimer
est ce que ce que par exemple si cette
réforme consiste à reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite vous êtes pour
mais je crois qu'il va y avoir des gros
débat dans la majorité sur le sujet et
vous ferez partie ceux qui seront suis
pas à la place où je fais les débats
dans la majorité moi je suis au
gouvernement j'ai des réformes à faire
et je remplis
ou alors vous avez un mouvement qui
s'appelle en commun précise a fait et
qui participera au défi comment les
autres au style justement il a pas il
apportera sa pierre à la discussion ça
d'accord évidemment est-ce que c'est
clair dans dix mois
barbara pompili vote emmanuel macron
pourquoi vous me posez encore cette
question est ce que j'ai envie de vous
la pose en de la pause est cinquante
fois j'ai répondu 50 fois oui oui je
vous redire une 51e fois oui mais je
crois que si on poser cette question à
tous les ministres de ce gouvernement et
du temps d'antenne pour autre chose
je dirais oui alors apparues des caisses
car oui alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
des écologistes qui organisait
mr e vous en avez l'expérience puisque
vous avez les culés précédente avec cinq
candidats pour le moment quel est celui
qui à votre avis pardon on est loupé un
ou deux noms il y avait la main de
madame duflot qui va pas duflot jean
battault delphine batho qui va se
présenter et vous avez aussi celui qui
était candidat dans la région paca pour
une licence centristes écologistes
centristes est qu est ce que vous avez
l'habitude il avait l'habitude
europe ecologie les verts de prendre
généralement le plus radical est-ce que
c'est à votre avis qui vont encore faire
cette fois côté on verra c'est vrai que
à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des primaires
le choix a été fait a été porté sur un
candidat qui était plus proche de la
base radicale des verts plutôt que sur
un choix qui serait le choix d'un
candidat plus rassembleur c'est ce qui
fait que à un moment on arrive aux
limites de ce que les verts peuvent
faire moi j'ai quitté ce parti il y a
cinq ans parce que il était toujours
dans une attitude protestataires dans
une attitude qui était très radicale et
dans une attitude qui ne permettait pas
de se confronter à la réalité à la
complexité du monde et d'y apporter des
solutions wiki choisissent de l'hexagone
et donc
donc moi ce nom mais ce que je vais vous
dirai ce que je veux répéter ici c'est
que l'écologie politique est loin de se
cantonner au vert moi si j'étais
allemande je serai je serai chez les
grünen pourquoi parce que les grünen ce
sont des écologistes qui ont décidé de
participer à des exécutifs que ce soit
au gouvernement central mais aussi dans
les länder
ils ont mit l'aimant clan ben oui vous
avez raison ils comprennent que la le
monde est complexe et que les réformes
c'est plus facile d'en parler c'est plus
dur à mettre ange et écologistes ça
c'est évitable
est ce que vous êtes à l'aise dans le
gouvernement et la majorité à laquelle
vous appartenez
sinon je n'y serai pas moi je suis
rentré dans ce gouvernement avec une
feuille de route claire et vous restiez
de gauche évidemment oui
essaie de faire c'est de mettre en place
des réformes des réformes très
importantes pour baisser nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre pour nous
préparer à affronter l'avenir pour
relancer l'économie grâce à l'écologie
ce qui est un point absolument essentiel
or était que le président de la
république n'ait pas tenu la promesse
d'une réforme des institutions qui
devrait forme assez faciles à faire qui
est celle de passer au scrutin à la
proportionnelle à sa c'est un grand
débat
le scrutin proportionnel je crois que
d'une manière plus globale
on doit réfléchir à la manière dont on
associe les citoyens la décision prise
sous le feu
voilà pour pour lutter contre
l'abstention je pense que la
proportionnelle peut être un outil ça
sera pas le seul
on doit on en a fait des expériences de
la convention citoyenne pour lectra par
exemple qui a ses qualités ses défauts
mais qui était un exercice très
intéressant et inédit
on doit continuer à réfléchir à comment
on fait pour que les citoyens se sentent
concernés par ce qui se passe en
politique parce que c'est leur vie
quotidienne
et pourtant il s'en désintéressent c'est
un vrai sujet mais je crois que ça on
aura l'occasion d'avoir de longs démo
vous êtes pour le contrôle final où je
suis pas une star de proportionner une
par une dose une part je vous ai versé
attentivement yves oui et je me disais
vous pourriez de candidate finalement la
primaire des écologistes avec en commun
oui mais je considère que les je
considère que les écologistes sont
beaucoup plus nombreux en dehors des
verts et de deux
vu que là bas si vous vous trompez pas
candidate à la primaire des écologistes
en jeu nice je ne serai pas quand je
fais les primaires des écoles et leurs
amis votre famille c'est la république
au mans primaire des verts c'est pas la
première dizaine et votre famille c'est
la république en marche
ma famille c'est la famille de
l'écologie au sens large mais là je suis
dans la majorité présidentielle et je
représente justement l'écologie sociale
au sein de cette majorité
merci merci à vous on va parler
d'inquiétude des agents de l'office
national des forêts 500 emplois vont
être supprimés dans les cinq ans qui
viennent à l'eau nf
le plan de restructuration a été votée
au conseil d'administration de l'ena il
ya quelques jours mais vraiment de façon
très très très limites puisqu'il a fallu
que ce soit le président qui arbitre à
la fin parce qu'il y avait égalité de
voix entre les pour et les contre et ses
agents de lodève sont soutenus par
beaucoup d'élus qui disent la forêt et
oublier la forêt abandonné est ce que la
forêt la grande sacrifiée justement
comme le disent les opposants à cette
réorganisation de l'eau nf
là on a deux sujets on a l'eau et n'est
fait on à la politique de la forêt des
deux sont évidemment liés on a une
politique de la forêt qui a été assez
longtemps négligé notamment dans le sens
du développement économique de la
filière
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs enjeux sur la
forêt il faut qu'on adapte la forêt au
réchauffement climatique
parce que les essences que nous plantons
aujourd'hui doivent être résistantes à
des évolutions de température dans les
décennies qui viennent on doit aussi
préparer la forêt à lutter contre le
risque incendie etc
et puis on doit développer la filière
bois qui est une filière qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas s'est développé dans notre
pays alors que nous promouvons la
construction en bois et c'était tout ça
avec 500 emplois alors le nf est un
outil est un outil avec des avec des
agents très important d'ailleurs j'étais
auprès de la semaine dernière pourra le
rôle qu'ils font dans la prévention des
incendies par exemple ils sont obligés
de travailler avec effectivement des
effectifs qui sont limitées parce que
l'état fait des efforts partout moi je
crois qu'à un moment il faut arrêter de
trop limité les personnels maintenant
sur les engagements d'intérêt général de
ménage puisque vous savez kluïev à des
anticorps est un epic donc ils ont des
activités qui sont des activités
lucratives des activités d'intérêt
général
l'état a décidé de rentrer de renflouer
entre guillemets les caisses sur des
missions d'intérêt général ils ont
encore voter une rallonge de 9 millions
d'euros l'a récemment
donc on oublie filiation du bois par
exemple ça peut être autre chose mais en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence à ce ne
sont pas les missions d'intérêt général
entend bien j'entends bien et donc ils
vont s'insérer dans une politique plus
large création de d'une filière bois qui
aujourd'hui est trop embryonnaire dans
notre pays il y en a marre d'avoir du
bois français qui part en chine et qui
revient transformé en france on va
cueillir maintenant les deux
parlementaires qui vont débattre avec
vous
sa boutique julien aubert bonsoir
bonsoir et tlr de vaucluse et vous avez
été aussi auteur d'un rapport
parlementaire sur le coût de la
transition énergétique en pointant
particulièrement les éoliennes et ça
tombe bien parce que c'est un sujet
aussi qui mobilise votre voisin guy
benarroch bonsoir soit vous êtes
sénateur europe ecologie les verts des
bouches du rhône ne vous est pas venu
dans le même train vous auriez plus
élaboré
il peut-être avant de parler des
éoliennes et c'est vous qui commencez
julien aubert est évidemment guy
benarroch pourraient embrayer au fur et
à mesure des réponses de la ministre
mais oui effectivement on est ministre
on est d'accord que la base de
l'écologie c'est lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
donc à une question que je ne parviens
pas à résoudre
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on dépense on
n'engage pas encore tout dépenser mais
entre 70 et 90 milliards d'euros pour le
soutien à des énergies renouvelables
électriques des l'éolien dont on sait
d'ailleurs qui provoque les polémiques
qu'on connaît qui finalement est une
petite partie du vrai fardeau qui est
surtout le fardeau dans le domaine du
chauffage dans le domaine des transports
sur lequel on a évidemment des besoins
de financement pourquoi mettre le paquet
entre guillemets sur cette énergie si
controversé dont on pourrait rappeler
aussi d'ailleurs
je dirais parfois l'inefficacité puisque
je prends par exemple le dernier mois de
juin à part le 12 et le 20 juin la
production éolienne en france et en
allemagne a été extrêmement faible
il ya même un jour on est atteint 2 8%
de la capacité installée
c'est pour vous dire que c'est vraiment
de la 2e mi-temps ce pardon parce qu'il
est passé les énergies renouvelables on
en a besoin on en a besoin parce que
nous avons besoin d'un mix énergétique
un mix électrique en l'occurrence
diversifiée on me répond souvent quand
je dis mais écoutez si on fait pas de
renouvelable qu'est ce que vous voulez
écouter on va faire du nucléaire bon
très bien sauf que quand nous avons
des agences comme l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui nous dit
que le renouvelable va compter pour 90%
de la production mondiale d'électricité
et qu' il y aura 10 % nucléaire personne
ne dit inverse et que au niveau de la
france
nous avons des scénarios de sortie fin
de sortie de changement du mix
électrique et que ces scénarios vont du
plus de nucléaire au moins nucléaire que
dans tous ces scénarios il ya une
augmentation très forte des
renouvelables
moi je dois défendre et je dois faire
avancer les rénergie renouvelable toutes
les énergies vous le savez bien ont des
qualités et des défauts c'est comme ça
mais à voir tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier
c'est très dangereux oui alors tous les
tous les oeufs dans le même panier mais
après je serai moins on pourrait très
bien élargir après on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir une programmation pleurer de
l'énergie qui fait des choix très fort
en disant on va un concentré l'essentiel
des moyens pour développer deux
électricité particulières qui sont
atteints mi dance et comme vous l'avez
dit c'est le mix électrique alors que
notre problème c'est notre dépendance au
gaz au pétrole qui sont donc
complètement si vous voulez or hors
champ dieu mériterait qu'on s'y attaque
si véritablement on veut baisser les
émissions de co2 non mais la dépendance
au gaz et au pétrole on s'y attaque en
l'occurrence puisque on électrifie nos
voitures qui sont quand même une des
grandes des grands des grandes émissions
de gaz à effet de serre le transport
c'est à peu près un quart de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un peu
moins nous avons aussi toutes les
programmes du plan de relance sur la
décarbonation de l'industrie donc là
nous utilisent tout ce qui est les
fourre tout ce qui est les appareils de
production qui utilisent aujourd'hui du
charbon qui utilise du fuel etc
nous les finançons des mets ton 4
milliard d'euros pour justement qu'il
passa décarbonation la décarbonation ça
va faire des électriques évidemment nous
soutenons le développement de la filière
hydrogène
nous soutenons les économies d'énergie
donc nous ne soutenons pas que les
renouvelables
mais les renouvelables et je parle bien
de tous les renouveler
abl doivent être développés dans notre
pays on est heureusement oui oui je vous
ai bientôt entre les deux la super entre
les deux et je suis étonné par la table
de mon collègue débuté de la région paca
parce que il parle du coût des éoliennes
très très bien et le coût du nucléaire
est-ce que vous avez comparé le coût du
nucléaire beaucoup d'une éolienne est ce
que vous savez combien va coûter
nucléaire au kilowattheure produit en
2030 par rapport au coût de l'éolienne
du kilowattheure produit par une
éolienne en 2030
je pose la question aux très clairement
moi je nous l'avons fait donc je peux
vous dire ne parlez pas que deux coups
en parlant de l'eonia l'éolien fait
partie d'un mix énergétique
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que nous
avons besoin de ce mix énergétique des
énergies renouvelables ça doit
représenter comme l'a rappelé barbara
poppy 90 % de notre production
énergétique y compris nucléaires y
compris d'ici 2050 au valium donc
aujourd'hui nous devons développer ces
filières nous devons investir au moins
autant sur les filières d'énergie
renouvelable que ce que nous avons
investi pendant des années sur le
nucléaire ou si elle est sûre sur les
énergies carbonées
c'est une nécessité c'est une nécessité
pour remplir ce que vous avez voté au
fait ce que vos collègues ont eux-mêmes
voté au sénat c'est une des rares choses
intéressantes qu'ils ont voté c'est de
rentrer dans l'objectif européen
c'est-à-dire des 55 % de diminution des
gaz à effet de serre dissident a parlé
tout à l'heure alors votre question à
barbara pompidou c'est quoi vingt ans
plus tôt alors barbara pop idol d'abord
vous avez parlé à juste titre la
production d'hydrogène des installations
photovoltaïques et d'éoliennes moi ce
que je déplore ce n'est pas ce que vous
annoncez c'est la réalité de ce qui
figure dans votre loi dans le projet de
loi que vous avez soumis au sénat par
rapport justement à ces mix énergétique
à ces énergies renouvelables pas passé
loin nous vous avons proposé un certain
nombre d'amendements parce que l'europe
est écologiste a proposé une loi climat
eu ce que nous avons appelé la vraie loi
que l'émail un certain nombre de
propositions sur ces énergies adopté les
à l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
reprenez l'air votre quote moi ce que je
vous propose monsieur sénateurs c'est
que vous veniez m'aider déjà à mettre en
place ce que nous avons déjà décidé
c'est à dire que nous avons le
développement des énergies renouvelables
à faire nous avons beaucoup
d'oppositions sur les éoliennes mais le
problème c'est que nous n'avons pas de
l'opposition que sur les éoliennes
onshore donc à terre nous avons des
oppositions sur les éoliennes en mer
nous avons des oppositions quand il ya
des projets de méthanisation
nous allons avoir je vous fiche mon
billet sur le photovoltaïque etc
donc on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
personnes qui viennent expliquer les
enjeux la complexité et expliquez vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure sur les coûts
de production
on va avoir des coûts de production
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l' agence
internationale de l'énergie qui vont
être trois à quatre fois supérieur pour
le nouveau nucléaire que les les
énergies renouvelables en moyenne la
question c'est la question c'est un
moment le portefeuille des français dont
le allah vous fêterez les deux
parlements
quelque chose mais quoi qu'on fait parce
que nous allons devoir de toute façon
investir sur notre mix électrique nous
avons 1 1
nous avons un parc nucléaire qui a
vieilli sens qu'il va falloir de toute
façon soit remplacé par du nouveau
nucléaire soit par des énergies je veux
bien répondre à la question est ce qu'on
est prêt à vous aider à ce qu'on est
prêt à aider le gouvernement mais ça
fait des années qu'on aide la société
française en général à avancer dans la
voie de la transition écologique et
énergétique
ça fait des années qu'on propose un
certain nombre de choses et encore une
fois ou bien entendu qu'on est prêt à
aider mais c'est ce qu'a déploré vos
potes vos prédécesseurs célèbre nicolas
hulot il y a besoin pour le gouvernement
d'avoir derrière une pression populaire
une pression citoyenne comme les
citoyens sont là et quand ils agissent à
votre demande avec la convention
citoyenne pour le climat la moindre des
choses pour un gouvernement c'est de
reprendre à son compte comme l'avait dit
emmanuel macron sophistes ces
propositions là vous ne l'avez pas fait
vous avez loupé le coche
oui bah écoutez moi je voulais dire
d'abord sur les coûts avec l'argent
qu'on met sur l'éolien moi je vous
reconstruit le parc nucléaire historique
qui a durée minimum 40 ans on peut durer
60 ans et fonctionne 75% du temps alors
que avec cet argent
vous me faites quelque chose qui
fonctionne 22 % du temps ces taux de
charge d'une éolienne vous le savez
parfaitement ses 20% à terre 40% en
offshore poser 60% en offshore flottant
ça c'est pas parce que les pales
tournent que ça produit de l'électricité
au sens si vous voulez ou de production
ça s'appelle le taux de charge et vous
le savez très bien
deuxièmement ils les font bien
électrique on m'avait répondu sur le
nucléaire nucléaire il devrait être à 80
% il est en baisse pour des raisons de
maintenance mgd mais oui mais c'est une
énergie qui stockables deuxièmement sur
le mix électrique mondiale d'accord que
les suédois les chinois reste que nous
nous partons d'une situation où le
nucléaire est prédominant enfin les
arguments disons nous devons nous devons
nous devons ne sont pas des arguments de
raison enfin je vous m'avez parlé de
l'hydrogène ou de la voiture électrique
on pourrait très bien faire du nucléaire
donc la question n'est pas c'est
totalement distinct de savoir quel mix
électrique qu'on a on a effectivement à
suivre on pourrait très bien faire
d'énergie de l'hydrogène nucléaire ce
serait d'ailleurs intéressant ou voir
des voitures électriques avec du
nucléaire
en revanche quand vous mettez 70 à 90
milliards d'euros sur l'éolien mais 7
milliards d'euros sur l'hydrogène
permettez moi de vous dire que en termes
de d'horizon moi je trouve qu'on met on
équilibre mende les choses devraient
bien faire des voitures à hydrogène
d'abord c'est ça non mais je veux dire à
la limite si vous voulez dans
l'allocation des revenus ça tourne pour
le comprendre quand vous mettez c'est un
effet alors pour être honnête il ya un
effet il s'intéresse du temps comme on a
commencé par le photovoltaïque
photovoltaïque et le solaire éolien
s'appelle s'ils voulaient dans les
comptes
reste qu'à un moment donné si on veut
réel ou et pour l'avenir il faut bien
évidemment arrêter d'aider ces énergies
d'ailleurs qui embête les français qui
tuent des oiseaux jeudi salle des
combins si gmail et de protection des
oiseaux
18 forcément que ça doit tuer des
oiseaux 01 03 la ligue de protection des
oiseaux est favorable à l'éolien
elle est favorable à l'éolien mais comme
toute activité l'éolien peut avoir
effectivement des des impacts sur la
biodiversité notamment sur les oiseaux
ou sur les chauves-souris et c'est pour
ça qu'on travaille avec les associations
pour faire en sorte que les
implantations des parcs se fasse à des
endroits où l'impact sur la biodiversité
est moindre ça s'appelle de la logique
après sur le reste on fabrique avec quoi
l'hydrogène
bah voilà et donc le dos et donc
l'électricité écoutez si vous voulez du
100% nucléaire moi je vous dis que c'est
dangereux c'est dangereux on a besoin
d'avoir un mieux diversifier le mix
après le taux de diversification du mix
et béni fera l'objet d'un débat et ça
tombe bien
à la rentrée nous allons avoir des
scénarios nous allons avoir six
scénarios qui sont des scénarios géré
par réseau transport d'électricité donc
en plus qui vont s'intéresser à la
question du stockage à la question des
réseaux à la question de tous les
intérêts et les défauts de chaque
technologie et sur la base de ce
scénario on va pouvoir débattre
on débattra plus en l'air là on aura la
vérité des prix on aura la vérité de
tous cas ce qui inclut telle ou telle
énergie à des énergies qui produisent
des déchets il ya d'autres énergies qui
demande d occupation des espaces etc
on aura un vrai débat mais tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que moi je serai
attentive à ce que le débat soit juste
et 2 qu'on fasse attention aux coûts et
qu'on fasse attention aussi à ne pas
retomber dans les dogmatismes kingking
tu alors julie tiqui une question
dogmatique sas est cette histoire de
l'énergie ne suis pas une question de
pratique là je suis d'accord avec mme
amara propice et une comparaison à faire
une comparaison des coûts déroutement
aujourd'hui de ce qu'a coûté nucléaire
encore une fois de ce qu'on exclue d'un
coup d'une énergie le traitement des
déchets si on inclut pas leur énergie
nucléaire forcément ça a dit
le prix du coût de l'énergie nucléaire
donc il faut faire uniquement cette
étude ont été faites et le coup sur les
oiseaux bien sûr qu'il faut tenir compte
et le coup sûr l'homme et les
dangerosité énergie nucléaire et les
accidents nucléaires si vous doutez des
pagodes si sa cote pause héros pour vous
vous dites faut tenir compte mais le
nucléaire a tué deux français en quarts
mais on ne sait pas que les français ici
d'énergie mondiale le charbon il joue
bien le jardin le charbon et le
nucléaire mais ce passionné c'est pas
nucléaire le sujet c'est le ce sont les
rôles et alors on va parler d'autre
chose arrivait n'arrange pas ce que vous
voulez parler des et des feux alors ce
sont les autres à faible émission vous
allez nous dire ce que c'est et nous
dire vous voulez en venir donner en fait
c'est adaf eux qui se reçoit une lune
est une excellente idée sur ces saisies
clair moins de circulation dans
certaines zones pour que ça pollue moins
voilà moi de circulation avec un
contrôle sur certains types de véhicules
en fonction de leur cap niveau de
pollution on va dire de telle façon à
petit à petit permettent dans ces zones
d'avoir moins de pollution parce que
tout simplement on sait très bien m à
quel point cette pollution des véhicules
tue chaque année un certain nombre de
personnes en france mais aussi à
l'étranger partout voilà on se bat pas
s'arrêter aux frontières et donc pour
limiter cesser cette pollution
atmosphérique et ses effets sur la santé
il faut limiter dans certaines zones la
circulation de ces véhicules nous a
proposé de le faire d'une manière pas
très rapide pas trop rapide mais quand
même d'une manière assez proche dans les
années qui viennent alors que
effectivement de recul en recul y
compris par le sénat on en arrive en
fait à des propositions qui ne servent
plus à rien c'est à dire qu'ils
repoussent qu une fois à bloquer vague
comme on dit dans le midi à certain
nombre de mesures
alors ça j'avais pas compris ça veut
dire ça mais c'est toujours trop tôt
c'est toujours toi voilà alors barbara
vont piller vous souhaitez qu'elle
accélère le mouvement est bien entendu
dans seulement deux fois l'accélération
vos lames et il faut l'accélérer aussi
sur les véhicules qu'on pourra mettre en
circulation hors bien sûr sur leur
niveau de pollution sur le niveau de
dangerosité sur leur sueur et puis il
faut inciter d'autres mobilité en
particulier par exemple c'était une de
nos mesures phares rod obligatoire et
général est forfait mobilité durable
alors
avez raison c'est encore un recul du
sénat le fait de rue de la droite vous
voulez dire très clairement oui
le fait de repousser de cinq ans la mise
en oeuvre des 2 c et des feux je
rappelle que c est des feux sont faites
pour lutter contre la pollution de l'air
qui tue 40 mille personnes par an c'est
la troisième cause de mort évitable en
france et les sénateurs ont considéré
qu'il était urgent d'attendre
alors que c'est tout simplement enfin
cesser les pots d'échappement sur les
poussettes des enfants c'est des choses
simples donc pour répondre à ça les aide
des feux sont un outil un outil
d'ailleurs qui existe à l'heure en sort
à faibles émissions
vous avez raison ça existe ailleurs en
europe où s'est mis en place
et d'ailleurs on tire des expériences de
ce qui se passe ailleurs parce qu'il ya
des endroits où ça se passe bien et
d'autres où il ya des décalages à faire
ce qui est important c'est de ne pas
empêcher la mobilité des gens et des
professionnels donc pour faire face à ça
on met en place un certain nombre
d'outils pour aider les gens à changer
de véhicule la prime à la conversion qui
a très bien marché
le bonus qui qui permettent de changer
sa voiture pour acheter une voiture qui
est moins émettrices ou électriques mais
aussi des voitures à essence on
développe les transports en commun on a
on a mis en place beaucoup d'appels à
projets pour développer les transports
en commun pour des gens puissent se
déplacer les prime à la conversion
concerne aussi les professionnels il
faut pas oublier des artisans qui ont
besoin avec leur camionnette de rentrer
en gisements une petite question est ce
que ce que fait heins hidalgo à paris
c'est un exemple pour vous est de plus
en plus de rues fermées à la circulation
des choses comme ça anne hidalgo elle
n'a le courage politique de mettre en
place un certain nombre de mesures parce
que c'est facile de se dire écologistes
en théorie et de le faire dans la
réalité il ya certes paris est un
exemple il ya certainement des choses
que j'aurais fait différemment il
n'empêche que elle met des choses en
place qu'elle y va ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est qu'on le fasse dans la
concertation et qu'on trouve des
solutions pour tout le monde masculine
le plus important pour moi c'est que les
zones à faibles émissions soient mises
en place mais que l'accompagnement au
tour pour tout le monde puisse se
déplacer correctement soit soit soit mis
en place
on peut pas faire l'un sans l'autre
voyez benarroch qui est d'accord
vous pourriez retourner europe écologie
verts ou vous peut-être avec une cour
martiale
j'oserais page oserait pas le dire de
cette façon là mais la différence
effectivement c'est que nous sommes
d'accord mais que beaucoup de mesure où
beaucoup de décisions qui sont à prendre
maintenant soit différée dans le temps
par le gouvernement et c'est ce que nous
reprochons et donc la loi c'est la
droite qui bloque le droit la droite a
n'a pas arrangé les choses au sénat
soyons clairs ella ella sur certains
panneaux mis certaine régression des
bons du point de vue c'est votre
c'est votre problème de santé publique
penser qu'on ne résout pas le problème
en en créant d'autres que ça va
forcément le bon moyen vous avez un
autre sujet trois mois les choses qui
m'a ému quand j'ai reçu ces gens du ce
et circassiens qui disait du cir
professionnels du cirque qui vivent avec
leurs animaux n'ont souvent d'ailleurs
pas un niveau d'étude très élaboré très
voilà ils sont souvent pas le
baccalauréat et qui expliquait désemparé
que finalement il avait été choisi comme
mesure symbolique dans un texte un peu
fourre-tout pour supprimer les animaux
dits sauvages qui sont en fait élever en
captivité depuis plus d'un demi siècle
dans les cirques et je voudrais savoir
quelle est la logique derrière quand on
sait que quand on parle des itinérances
d'animaux vous avez d'autres activités
ou iliad est inhérent si on parle
animaux en cage y en ad'autres donc est
ce que c'est le premier domino dans
votre esprit ou est-ce que c'était pour
dire ben voila je prends un exemple moi
je trouvais ça injuste
au delà du spectacle populaire parce
qu'ils en vivent et parce qu'il soit
carrément un niveau répond moi je trouve
que c'est aussi la noblesse de la
politique d'être capable de prendre des
mesures qui vont qui sont en lien avec
l'évolution de notre manière de voir les
choses et notamment de voir notre
relation avec l'animal
ça a évolué nous avons aussi des études
scientifiques qui nous montre ce que
nous ne savions pas avant que
l'itinérance pour les animaux et pour
certains animaux en particulier n'est
pas adapté à
alors bien être tout simplement au fait
de vivre correctement
et donc c'est pour ça que nous arrêtons
l'itinérance pour les animaux évidemment
c'est quelque chose qui prend du temps
nous avons pris d'autres mesures nous
avons pris des mesures sur les
delphinariums nous avons pris des
mesures sur les visons nous avons pris
les mesures sur les eaux aussi pour que
les eaux adaptent leur enclos et 9 et
julien baer c est ce que c'est le début
de la fin des animaux sauvages ainsi
rappelé que 0 est ce que c'est le
premier élément parce que demain il y
aura pas vous mélangez des choses très
différentes des visons on les tue donc
on est cirque itinérant mais c'est
quelque chose qui prend du temps moi
j'ai annoncé en septembre dernier
là nous sommes dans la phase où nous
avons beaucoup de discussions notamment
avec les circassiens parce que c'est
vrai qu'on leur demande une évolution
dans leur travail
on leur demande de se priver de ces
animaux sauvages avec lesquels il
travaillait en itinérance l'ayant là ça
ne concerne pas les cirques qui sont des
cirques qui tablaient sur place le
travail est en train de se faire
d'ailleurs je passe un message à cette
occasion les textes ne sont pas sortis
les décret normalement devrait sortir
d'ici septembre je penserai signé en
septembre parce que nous travaillons aux
conditions quels animaux en keynes
animaux commencent en premier ou en lait
mais on peut pas faire ça n'importe
comment
évidemment on travaille sur la
reconversion des circassiens ce que je
peux dire simplement c'est que
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les animaux les cirques avec
animaux continuent de travailler et
c'est normal ils ont le droit de le
faire un joli en baisse ce matin je suis
jamais témoin d un bon vin les 500
animaux ça marche pas 2 il ya une
demande populaire
3 quand on fait la transhumance et qu'on
va mettre les moutons on bouge aussi les
énormes aux et quatre cantons fédéral
quel show ces le contre-argument demain
peut conduire la disparition d'un
certain nombre d'activités la crainte
aimer c'est très bon de faire un détour
maintenant par le filet avec vous nous
attendra 100 robes en soie vincent une
question que font circuler vos lecteur
ou le téléspectateur c'est laquelle les
réseaux sociaux également bonsoir
francis bonsoir barbarin pompili c'est
l'étude
esteban de santé publique autour de la
contamination de 100 % de la population
française 1,4 entre 90 et 100 % de la
population française par des métaux
lourds ce qui est assez étonnant ce qui
est assez fascinant c'est que santé
publique que le france décrit avec
beaucoup de précision le phénomène y
compris chez les enfants
mais finalement ne préconise aucune
solution
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait barbara
pompili ont fait rien alors d'abord
cette étude
elle fait partie de plusieurs études en
fait qui qui se suivent depuis un
certain temps sur ces métaux lourds
d'abord il faut faire la différence
entre détecter des métaux lourds et le
danger pour la santé publique
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que vous
avez des métaux qui sont dans votre
corps détectable détectables que j'ai
dont je pense j'ai il y à des normes il
ya une réglementation il y à des niveaux
d'exposition et la réglementation
évidemment est fait pour que vous n'ayez
pas plus d'exposition que vous dites
aujourd'hui n'y a pas de danger
non on va d'abord on va on va étudier
les résultats
ce qu'il faut faire d'une manière
générale c'est que vous avez une
alimentation qui doit être diversifiée
qui permet de réduire ses niveaux de
métaux ne manger que de loin ce sont par
exemple par exemple le poisson les
conseils nutritionnels ces deux fois par
semaine ensuite il y a certains métaux
comme le cadmium par exemple dont on
sait qu'ils sont apportés par notamment
des ingrédients qui est d'aider des
céréales qui ont été faites avec des
engrais azotés
on a mis dans la loi climat résilience
une trajectoire de baisse d'utilisation
de ces engrais justement pour limiter
donc la place de sauveteurs à bouger
d'ailleurs le sénat à m
comment supprimer cette mesure mais nous
allons faire en sorte qu'elles
reviennent dans la version finale
ça va bouger merci vincent merci julien
aubert merci guy benarroch d'être venu
dans l'histoire public envers si le
renard aux réseaux mais aussi d'avoir
participé aux auditions publiques qui
revient à lundi en direct la distincts
votés en bonne soirée au soir merci
[Musique]